He thinks I'm Spider-Man
anyway
I need to really up my game here
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Marvel's been revealing more characters
that are supposed to be featured in Deadpool 3,
so we'll break it all down.
Some of these are new ones that are heavily connected.
The Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
Big surprise.
If you didn't watch that series,
there were a couple cool Wolverine Easter eggs
that I'll point out later in the video
and as you would expect, they're heavily
tied to the original X-Men movies and characters
that are going to be in the movie, or their characters
that were connected to those people in the comics
that Fox never actually got into
in their Marvel X-Men movies or Fantastic Four movies.
This video will mostly be about the characters
that are connected specifically to Wolverine
since he's such a huge part of the movie.
Hugh Jackman's version of Wolverine,
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They're going to be filming Deadpool
three for a little while longer, so we'll learn more
about what's actually going on with the movie
and speaking of Deadpool three, Kevin
Viki himself was actually spotted at a Wrexham game
with Ryan Reynolds recently.
The past weekend.
no idea what he was doing there.
Probably just taking in a casual game because it is
kind of the holidays like most people have gone
on holiday break for the most part, But I just did
a video about x 23 returning in Deadpool three.
They were trying to get an older version
of her back in the movie and now it looks like
we might be getting the dachshund character
mostly known as Wolverine Son
His real name is Akihiro,
but he's going by a couple of aliases
in the comics, mostly dark,
and he became the new Wolverine in Norman Osborn's
dark Avengers briefly during Marvel's Dark Reign era,
which they're kind of doing right now in Marvel.
Phase five.
we're kind of heading into a situation like that
during Captain America for Brave New World,
even though that will be a little bit different
from what happened in the comics.
he became one of apocalypse, his four horsemen
representing death just like Wolverine did before him.
X 23 was also one of the four horsemen.
But she was war.
Papa bless. Like father, like son.
one of the big differences, though,
between Dak and X 23
is that Dragon is Wolverine's biological son.
In x 23 is just a female clone of Wolverine.
more recently he's been going by the name Fang.
He was resurrected on Krakatoa and they've been
using him in the more recent X-Men comics.
He shows up all over the place.
he's even part of a big crossover
storyline with the Eternals right now.
Like we just had the Eternals during Marvel Phase four.
Eventually we'll see some of the Eternals
characters come back and this sort of teased
the idea of celestials seeds in what the Celestials
are actually doing around the multiverse,
they just made him an evolutionary caretaker,
a herald of the celestials with the dead seed.
They're meant to rival the Phenix Force
and their level of power.
But since this a comic book thing
and they're always like ten years ahead
of what they're doing in the movies, I wouldn't worry
too much about what they're doing in the X-Men comics
right now, even though there's a bunch of crazy stuff
happening in Deadpool three, most of that is drawing on
like really old classic X-Men stuff or stuff
that goes even further back than that.
Before the original X-Men movies, Dickens.
Mother was a Japanese woman.
That Wolverine was married to after World War Two
when he'd been living in Japan.
they got into his backstory, living in Japan around
World War Two a little bit during the Wolverine movie.
Her name was Sue during the last stages
of her pregnancy with Dak.
And in 1946, she was killed by the Winter Soldier.
Here's we get to the Big Winter Soldier crossover
storyline in the Falcon and Winter Soldier stuff.
he was trying to use her death and Wolverine's
unborn child to lure him out
in an attempt to capture Wolverine
in return into custody on Madripoor.
that was that lawless island
that we saw them visit during Falcon and Winter
Soldier, where Sharon Carter's
power broker operations were happening.
when they're walking around the Princess bar
that you see here, it was a huge location for Wolverine
in all of his comics, even though this was happening,
like right after Avengers
Endgame early in Marvel, Phase four,
and they hadn't quite got to the point
of revealing a ton of mutants in the MCU,
They tried to hint at Wolverine,
the X-Men characters, as much as possible
during this after winter soldier leaves.
Because Jackman was a mutant, he got all of Wolverine's
powers, including his healing factor.
He winds up surviving and gets found by the ancient
and powerful mutant
named Romulus, who has power similar to Wolverine's.
and you find out this is all part of a larger plot
where he was
secretly manipulating Wolverine his entire life.
so he winds up leaving the baby with adoptive parents
who named him Archie Hero after the adoptive father,
the local children taunt him, naming him Deacon,
which in Japanese is meant to mean mongrel.
so even though most people think of him as dark
and he's hated that name, his entire life
is basically an insult
he was given as a child years later, around 1959,
Romulus starts training back in to be a killer,
using all of his mutant powers
and eventually tries to orchestrate a fight
between him and his father.
Wolverine in his grand plan is for the survivor of that
fight father on son to become Romulus.
His successor.
there was this whole storyline
where he tried to present himself.
He told a bunch of lies about his back story, claiming
he was this apex mutant.
But you have things like the Phenix Force
other way more powerful cosmic entities out there.
So they're like way more powerful things
in the Marvel Universe.
end, even though Darkwing grows to hate Wolverine
because he feels abandoned by him, like,
why didn't you come look for me?
I have mutant powers. Of course I was going to survive.
it becomes very cat's in the cradle.
And that's kind of their story across all the comics.
Like even up to present day.
Daken hates his father, Wolverine.
Then he goes on to have a whole bunch of adventures
in the comics separate from Wolverine,
just trying to get out from under his shadow.
He eventually x 23, they worked together, but he's done
both things like he's kind of a neutral character,
like he's done both very evil
things, really dark things, and he's also helped people
to so generally comic book writers have used him
is like very, very dark, like much darker
version of Wolverine, even though Wolverine himself
was sort of engineered to be an anti-hero,
really dark type of character
when he was first created,
the uber violent version of Wolverine.
generally, I would say that
x 23 is kind of like the opposite direction of that,
like she's meant to be the more hopeful iteration
of the Wolverine character.
My assumption.
Just because there's so much stuff
going on in this movie
is that if Dan winds up making it into the final cut
is he's mostly a background character
or the only reference and verbally
just because the whole idea is that
Deadpool is jumping around the multiverse
using cable's time travel device,
trying to find the perfect version of Wolverine
until he eventually discovers
the Hugh Jackman's version is the perfect version
is meant to be another joke about Kevin Feige
recasting Wolverine in real life,
like recasting Hugh Jackman with a new version,
a new actor, ultimately saying that Hugh Jackman
is the perfect Wolverine and he'll never be able
to recast him with a better actor.
this is kind of why they're designing the movie
to be Deadpool Kills the Fox Marvel Universe,
but also do it sort of like a Spider-Man
No Way home kind of movie, like X-Men, No Way Home,
where they honor everything that came before
before they do a bunch of big re castings.
And at some point during the movie Wolverine
and Deadpool will have to fight a bunch of really
hardcore, darker versions of all the classic X-Men
actors that are coming back from those original movies.
So it'll be like different versions of the characters,
variants of the characters to make a Loki reference.
Because Loki will be a big crossover series
with Deadpool three, We even spotted
some TVA characters during that last big footage
drop of all those Deadpool three scenes.
basically the movie is taking place after the events
of Loki season two,
where the TVA resumes normal operations.
But they're mostly focusing
on searching for king variants like the whole time
variance authority becomes
more like the king variance authority.
just picture miss Minutes trying to deal with Deadpool,
Deadpool Wolverine trying to escape from the TVA.
I've already done a much larger video about all the new
scenes and Easter eggs that they released recently.
Ryan Reynolds did a big post about it
in a bunch of parody posts on top of it,
like these are him clowning on some of the Deadpool
three scenes that everybody got to look at.
generally, all this X-Men stuff that they're doing
is meant to take place in another timeline,
another universe,
so that they don't wind up trampling on the continuity
of the original X-Men movies or like the Logan movie.
in generally all the footage
that we actually got to look at is from a specific
part of the movie, like almost the exact same scene
where they're all fighting classic X-Men and Fantastic
Four characters from the Fox Marvel movies
in other classic Easter
eggs like they had the fantastic hour here,
but it's a version based on the one
from the original Fantastic Four comics
back in the 1960s, not from the one in the movies
in it's being driven not by Fantastic Four characters,
but by Toad from that original Bryan
Singer X-Men movie.
They even had a Hot Rod had version of Red School's
car from the first Captain America movie.
suits meant to be a mishmash of Easter eggs
from older Marvel movies and stuff
that wasn't in the actual movies
like Stewart, stuff from the comics in general.
that's kind of why
I think that they're on the Void planet
from the Loki series when this is happening,
because that's essentially where all that stuff gets
dumped, like stuff from all over the multiverse,
Easter eggs from all over the comics and stuff
that was not in the TV shows, in the movies,
it would also explain why all the versions
of the X-Men characters
that they wind up fighting here are way
more hardcore, in a way more comic book to
there's even supposed to be a couple of scenes
clowning on the Avengers
assemble moment at the end of Avengers
Endgame and the final battle
like Captain America's Avengers Assemble moment
with a bunch of variants of the character,
like a bunch of different versions of Deadpool.
you just see the picture.
A much bigger version of what we saw during Loki season
one Episode five with like all those other Loki's
that banded together on the Void
and were fighting each other,
really
hoping we actually see alligator Loki
at some point during the series.
But I think part of the idea is that
he escaped the void with kid Loki.
there's a whole bunch of big stuff coming up next
big multiverse series we do have it'll be sort of
connected to all this stuff that's going on is
what if season two episodes that'll start next week.
I'll be doing videos for all of that,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channels
so you don't miss any of it.
is speaking of all the lowkey stuff
that's going on during Deadpool three there is Loki's
multiverse tree from after the events of Loki season
two in the what if season two trailer.
you always wondering when they actually planned this
because it takes forever like years to do animation
related stuff.
are not totally expecting Deadpool to show up during
what if season two.
I think that'd be more like a what if season
three kind of target And for X-Men related characters
just in general, Fantastic Four characters
Just because I think they want to debut
the new live action versions in the MCU
in like the new Fantastic Four movie before they start
doing a lot of animated, fantastic force stuff.
air because we have X-Men 97 episodes
that are coming right after
What if season two episodes
they don't want to steal any of X-Men 97 Thunder.
I just did a big teaser trailer video for that,
so I'll link it below in the description.
lot of people
also asking if Deadpool is going to show up
during X-Men 97 episodes
because they're already working on Season two.
It's always possible
there was a version of Deadpool in the original X-Men,
the Animated series, but obviously it wasn't
Ryan Reynolds version of the character.
So So they do rope in brand new Deadpool stuff too.
The new X-Men
97 episodes, it'd be a little bit different.
click. Here for my other Deadpool three video.
With all those clips of Deadpool
fighting the Fantastic Four in the X-Men characters,
it looks crazy and click here for my brand new
What If Season two trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe in maximum effort!